[Music]
feeding time at the zoo is like a
military
operation to keep all the residents fed
teranga's kitchens never seem to
shut and the live food unit known as the
bug house is quite literally always
buzzing it's full of Little Critters
that are bred on site and others that
are ordered in all of the insects that
we order in come in life the main reason
is insectivorous animals don't see a
dead bit of meat and think food they
need that movement that stimulation to
make them want to go after and Chase and
hunt the
prey niis thank you I'll wait for your
call bye this morning Christine is
preparing weekly orders for the zoos
insect devores or insect eating animals
the orders have to be um very precise to
make sure the correct amounts go
out we spend a lot of time putting all
of this together for it to happen all in
one day we're sending one to nocturnal
two to retreat these bags and boxes are
packed full of insects in all shapes and
sizes this trolley is full of beetle are
they so most people are pretty familiar
with mealworms the reason they're called
mealworms is that they're actually kept
in brand or like mey sort of stuff and
that's what they eat morning out is the
ordering Christine has worked here for
four years and she loves her bugs oh
they adorable look at those little faces
these little
mandibles insects are the cutest this
cute little just soft crawling around
it's a really comforting feeling for
[Music]
me one of the most important roles of
the bug house is to breed insects
including house
flies this one net will produce a week's
worth of maggots this net alone produces
20 kilos in a week every day we put it
in egging tray and when we get it out
they are chalk full of maggots they are
so thick in there the containers
actually feel warm but maggots are just
the first stage of housefly development
that is fed to the hungry
insector fly pupet is like the Crysis
for a butterfly but for flies the next
day AG is pupe and they're just as much
in demand they're little packets of
protein wrapped in a little case there's
this beautiful grainy sensation like
putting your hand into rice or seed and
they're just they're quite cool I will
admit they do have a bit of an unusual
smell on an average week we aim to
produce about 20 kilos of pupe this is
actually our week's haul collected from
our fly room to stop them all hatching
into flies
we're going to freeze it we want to have
the bigger sizes for the majority of our
animals other than that the really small
stuff is actually great because we can
use some of the really small hatched
flies to feed our really small
spiders with each stage of the fly life
cycle passing in just a few days timing
is everything especially in the maggot
room so these guys believe it or not the
ones I'm harvesting today they're 5 days
old tomorrow when they're 6 days old
they'll start pupating and we'll Harvest
on day
seven uh if we leave it to day eight
they will be flies these guys live on
brand uh effectively cereal and they get
nice and big on it too which is very
very lovely we've got 16 trays to
collect today so there's a lot of hungry
mous to feed out there and they all
quite love these little tiny tiny
maggots with her maggot orders nearly
done Christine completes the weekly
inscore buffet with some crunchy
crickets which are also bread at Tango
okay we go through different sizes so
the larges we only go through about
5,000 a
week but we go through a hell of a lot
more smalls so every day when we set up
our large crickets we actually put in an
egging tray something like this and
they'll just lay these beautifully
almost translucent eggs that are very
very tiny and thin and in
about 9 to 11 sometimes 14 days they'll
hatch
and they're incredibly tiny these
hatched this morning and these are very
essential for our crowberry breeding
program so the cowberry frogs are very
very tiny when they're young and they
have to eat really tiny
food like every animal in teranga's care
even the insects are cherished until
they're eaten of
course so we're just pouring the
Crickets all into here crickets they
like being being sheltered so when they
get buried in the vermiculite they're
actually not that upset it's safe it's
dark Predators can't find them we want
to make sure that we're providing the
best welfare for these guys so that in
turn they can provide the best welfare
to the animals they're fed to so when
these guys are happy and healthy the
animals that eat them will also be happy
and healthy half of this tub is going to
nocturno house and half of it going to
our Carnival team when it comes to
Counting how many crickets we're
assigning to each department
we have to eyeball it it would take me
quite a while to individually count,
1500 crickets into the tubs and that's
just a little bit silly for this morning
and with thousands of hungry mouths
waiting there's no time for that
Christine's only priority is to get the
insects packed and out for delivery as
quickly as possible this is usually done
within 90
minutes cuz after a certain point the
zoo is closed to all vehicles so our
delivery truck can't get through if
we're running late it can stop function
in the rest of the zoo cuz if they don't
have their food on time certain feeds
can't
happen and that's the last thing anybody
or any animal
[Music]
wants teranga's reptile house is home to
a pair of elderly rhino
iguanas hello sweet girl hello basar
come on in go who are a bit of a
favorite with keeper Emma we have
Tabasco here who is 24 years old uh
she's the boss of the exhibit and we
also have blue and he's our 28-year-old
male Rino
uana they are currently in a
relationship and they have produced many
babies over the years they're a
beautiful
couple they are a terrestrial iguana so
in the wild these guys would be found in
the Dominican Republic and Haiti and
they're from quite a dry environment
they really do well in our Australian
heat and when we look at them they truly
do look like little
dinosaurs so that little Rhino horn on
her nose there that's where they get
their name from and those big chunky
Jaws
are mostly for display but they also
mean that she's got a very strong bite
she's got a lot of jaw power yes she's
telling me to go away at the moment
I just
wait
Tabasco I know you're the
boss but sadly age brings
complications and keepers have noticed
that blue has been a bit off color
lately hey little Excursion buddy we do
like to keep a pretty close eye on our
aging animals to make sure that they're
in the best condition that they can be
he's enjoying his little Chariot
right we have noticed that his left eye
has been squinting a little bit lately
so that could be a sign of a cataract or
some sort of other underlying issue
let's pop him in here lizards rely on
their excellent Vision so this is a red
flag for vet Gabby so do you think he's
been able to see out of his left eye
since I think his yeah his Visions
dropped quite significantly and we've
Tri it with food as well and putting it
on his left side he just doesn't even
see that it's there but he can see you
with his right eye yeah AB he's very
responsive good so we'll approach him
from the left let's do that Safety First
blue Must Be Sedated before the team can
put him on anesthetic
gas but that's easier said than done oh
you're a stinky liard not
skinny he's a strong lizard he's got a
big neck and some big gels I'm just
going to right it's coming from
okay here we
[Music]
go sleepy T beautiful okay yep before
Gabby can intubate blue she must ensure
he's had enough
gas and that's Complicated by the fact
that reptiles can hold their breath our
goal is to get an airway access to him
so I want to be able to put a tube into
his draa for two reasons number one it's
it's safe if I have access to his Airway
and it means that we can breathe for him
if he stops breathing which reptiles
often do you may well jump you stand by
Rhino iguanas are armed with powerful
jaws and sharp teeth so the team must be
certain he's fully asleep he's really
good at closing his jaw with a lot of
power behind it so I'd really rather my
fingers not be in his mouth at that
time
yeah a little bit more he was
[Music]
pretending located on pctures Sydney
Harbor Tanga is one of the most
spectacular zoos on the
planet but some of teranga's most
important work takes place in a car
park so we've got hundreds of hundreds
of species here at throng Gazo that a
lot of people get to see on a daily
basis but there's a lot of things out
the back that people don't see and here
is one of our I guess conservation
facilities that people wouldn't be aware
of keeper Michael is doing crucial work
with an iconic and endangered Australian
species the tiny Northern cobery frog at
the moment cuz they're just warming up
out of their winter Slumber we're doing
this little I guess small health checks
on them make sure they all look good
make sure they they all look healthy
they're all alert and active and so far
everything we've seen seems
perfect so these little Northern C frogs
are pretty special they're brightly
colored one of our most brightly colored
frogs they're unique to Southeast region
of Australia so they're only found up in
the High Country up in the areas like
the snowy mountains in Kiosco and and
just the bordering areas of the act as
well they're a walking frog so they're
not a jumping frog you won't see these
guys jumping along so they're a little
bit different to most frogs that people
think about in their backyards where
they lay their eggs in ponds or in in
rivers these guys lay their eggs in
terrestrial moist Moss nests these are
guys are actually poisonous not
poisonous to me and that's not why I'm
wearing gloves I'm wearing gloves more
from the quarantine aspect they
sequester some toxins in their skin some
alkaloids from the ants and mites and
other invertebrates they eat but they
actually synthesize their own toxins as
well which makes them immune to most
predation that means the cobery Frog's
toxins would likely kill any predator
unlucky enough to eat one so clearly
Predators aren't the reason these frogs
are
endangered in the world we don't know
exactly how many are left but there's
probably around a few thousand and the
primary factor driving these guys to
towards Extinction is an introduced
disease it's caused by a fungus called
krid fungus and this fungus arrived in
Australia back in the late '70s early '
80s and it it spread throughout the
eastern part of Australia first and
unfortunately we lost we think six
species to the fungus and many more like
the crwby frogs are right on the brink
so this is really a safeguard for the
species what you can see in the
containers here every container's got
between four and six of these little
Northern crowberry frogs in them so that
way if anything happens to this species
in the wild and they disappear totally
we've got a good insurance population
here and hopefully once we work out
better ways to aate kitd fungus in the
wild we'll be able to really boost
population numbers back up again with a
broader genetic range of the species as
we can I personally really love working
with these little guys uh for a couple
of reasons one is my interest is
conservation management but secondly the
challenges that go along with working
with small amphibians amphibians are
amazing in terms of how they breed how
they reproduce
every species is quite
different the challenge of conserving
threatened species is something that
really drives me and the one of the
primary Reasons I'm here at
Tanga and even more exciting for Michael
is around this time each year he sees
the payoff for his labor of
love here are our Northern cby frog Tad
Pooles and these T Poes are pretty
important these little guys here are the
start of a new insurance
population
[Music]
one of teranga's most recent additions
is a family of the world's biggest
rodents hey boys Cy Cappies the cppy bar
native to South
America come on
guys so these five brothers came to us
uh from New Zealand 12 months ago and we
uh purpose built this new new habitat
for them and since arriving they've been
enjoying their new environment perhaps a
little too much in the wild capibara are
semi- aquatic so they eat both
terrestrial and aquatic plants um but
they they are mainly grass eating
rodents and a single Capi Bara can eat
up to 3 kilos of grass in a single day
they've pretty much destroyed all the uh
the grass in this exhibit they've
absolutely smashed it
yeah but as the cap bars mature keepers
are noticing it's no longer happy
families they are a funny Bunch they
have the similar kind of traits that
You' find in in five brothers no matter
what species you
are they're reaching an age of almost 2
years old now and that's an age when
they each starting to develop
individually um and because they're all
slightly different individuals they're
they're developing a slightly different
rate so we're seeing the the Dynamics of
this group changing they are interacting
with each other slightly differently as
they start to reach that mature
age keeper Johnny has identified the
brother that's really asserting his
dominance over the rest so this is
Rodney so he is the formerly the run of
the litter now the the heaviest the
biggest the boldest of the five brothers
um he's the one that's been causing uh
all the trouble that we've had recently
in this
group him and one of his cohorts Pedro
have decided to pick on one of their
brothers and it's it's little behaviors
like chasing him into the pool and
making sure he doesn't come out uh or or
chasing him away from feeding
spots and one sibling seems to be the
regular Target of Rodney's attacks this
is Carlos he's the victim of the uh the
Discord and aggression that we've seen
in the group uh most recently and you
can see a couple of open wounds on his
body at the moment which I'm being very
careful uh when touching he's copped a
few bites from his bigger brother
Rodney and as you can see he's uh he's a
bit nervous at the moment around any of
the other uh for boys and he has very
much been uh put down to the bottom of
the pile in terms of hierarchy in this
group in the short term we're monitoring
the capibara group more closely and then
we're also going to bring the Vets down
here and see what the options are in
terms of quelling the aggression and
trying to sort out uh some of the some
of the Discord that's happening with
this group and try and bring Harmony
back into the capibara
environment we really want to nip it in
the bud before it escalates to something
more than
this
P good across teranga many animals rely
on live food for nutrition and
enrichment and the food production unit
affectionately known as The Bug House
provides this vital
service food technician Christine is
racing against the clock to get the
weekly orders packed and on the delivery
truck before the zoo opens the
deliveries go all across the zoo there's
so many precincts that he goes to I
think the only one that isn't included
in the run is the Marine Mammal team cuz
they eat fish they don't eat
bugs first stop for driver Martin is the
bird kitchen morning morning we're an
average of 10 kilos of bugs are
delivered every single week our bird
section is the only Department that gets
all three stages of fli they love their
maggots they love their pupe and they
also love their live flies
but today it's not just the clock that
Martin is racing it's also the sun
seasonally with the deliveries we want
to be very aware of the temperature if
it's going to be a really hot day we
want to have everything on the truck
really quick very fast here's your buds
today cheers mate awesome that stuff's
Frozen okay put the frz now thanks man
have a good day winter we can be a
little bit more relaxed in how long we
leave stuff out but in summer it's on
gone and back in a freezer as quickly as
we can make
it morning good morning got our bug
delivery yeah do you want an inside yeah
that'd be great thank you so
much next customers are the miria cats
make a bit of mess who have been
impatiently waiting for Danielle to
deliver their
breakfast okay little Mar's
marries M cats are omnivorous so they
like to eat fruit and vegetables and a
whole lot of of insects in the wild
their favorites are scorpions if a
scorpion was to bite a meat nothing
would happen they're immune to the
scorpion venom so as part of their diet
we do feed them a lot of insects and one
of these things is fly pupe you can see
they really like it they like it so much
that they have these little scuffles and
these little tiffs over it it's every
individual for themselves when it comes
to fly pupe cuz it is a tasty little
treat Meats have very high metabolisms
cuz they're active all day so they burn
their food quite quickly so we do need
to give them small feeds regularly so
this is just part of one of those feeds
that they get throughout the
day another mouthwatering morsel are the
Crickets which are loaded into a
man-made termite mound to tantalize
these little carnivores taste buds the
carnivore team A500 large crickets in
there order there's one that will last
them for just a
week while the Crickets keep the Mir
cats busy the next Bug House delivery is
eagerly
anticipated blue the 28-year-old rhino
iguana has been having some trouble with
his left eye and this morning fed Gabby
is trying to solve the mystery I just
love his little thighs he's in beautiful
condition you're an old boy yeah yeah
although he's an older lizard he still
has a good set of teeth and a powerful
jaw which makes intubation a delicate
and lengthy business it really
stimulates them if you open their mouth
when they're once they're asleep and if
you start putting a tube near his Airway
he will
react so he has to be nice and
asleep
okay let's give him another go bit of
anesthetic
spray we want to ensure that we don't
squash the
[Music]
tube okay so we'll leave that in his go
it takes nearly an hour for blue to be
fully intubated which gives Gabby the
green light to start the
procedure
you can see his cataract here pretty
easily a cataract is when the lens has
changes in it to make it look white the
lens is made up of fibers and the fact
that they are aligned perfectly makes it
actually see
through so when you get inflammation and
changes in the lens those fibers don't
align so perfectly so you can see
them while the Cataract is restricting
Blue's fish
it shouldn't be causing any pain how
long has he been squinting for few weeks
that we've seen when you're trying to
discern whether or not he is in pain
obviously he can't tell us but he'll
squint so squinting is often a sign of
pain one of the most painful things you
can have in an eye is an ulcer on the
corne and so this dye just helps us pick
one up if there's one
there he's got a tiny little ala on the
corn okay it's only
small unrelated to the Cataract yeah so
it's on the outside of ey
y whether or not that's enough to cause
the squinting is Up For Debate it's but
we're going to treat him with pain
relief and we're giving him some
antibiotics Gabby flushes the eye clean
with some saline and then begins a
thorough examination of this aging
iguana I'm also looking for any crepitus
in the joints which just means
crunchiness which can indicate
arthritis so far so good he's very good
for a 28-year-old while Everything feels
okay only x-rays will reveal any serious
deterioration he looks so cute in that
position just like look at that
muscle just on first view his hips look
great his ankles look great his knees
look
good the last thing on the list today is
to get some blood and Gabby draws it
from an intriguing part of Blue's
Anatomy lizards and snakes have a vessel
that runs underneath their vertebrae of
their tail it's like a sinus rather than
an actual vein and pinpoint accuracy is
crucial as it's not the only precious
piece of equipment hiding in the T end
of this lizard most of their
reproductive organs in the tail itself
as well that's where he's are yep and
he's got a a double Banger too he's got
two of them got one on the right one on
the
left that's where I'll leave
that oh there's the blood Gabby will
send Blue's blood to pathology for
analysis it's all part of the hospital's
General Health check for its geriatric
animals he's up he's up it's an absolute
thrill to work with blue I think he's
one of the more unique animals we have
here and his exam's gone really well
last year he had a bit of stiffness in
his right elbow and that's resolved all
his joints move really well he's got
good range of motion in his joints
indicating that there's no arthritis
there and that's confirmed on the
radioraps how's he going he breathing
niely okay I'm happy for you to take it
yeah they kicked up the stink before
but now it looks pretty happy
and just as well for While Blue may look
pretty good on the outside he's got an
unseen problem Brewing on the
inside sadly once it makes itself known
it may be too
[Music]
late back at teranga's mundane looking
cluster of shipping containers keeper
Michael's vital work with the endangered
Northern cobber frog is paying
off as the Next Generation finds their
feet
literally quite a few changes have
happened here in the greeing facility
the northern cowberry frog tadpoles have
now mostly metamorphosed into frogs so
in this container we're looking at at
the moment there's five all five little
guys from this container of
metamorphosed we have four that have
fully resorbed their tail and we have
one who's still got a little bit of tail
resorption to go he's got his beautiful
crobby frog patting beautiful uh cby
frog colors but he's still got quite a
bit of a tail so at the moment he can't
eat all his energy at the moment is
coming from that tail resorbing into his
body so in maybe another I'd say four to
5 days time he'll reabsorb that tail and
in about a week's time he'll be able to
start to start feeding as a frog and
start eating little crickets and little
invertebrates these little tadpoles have
gone through significant changes in
around a
fornite so this little guy I've got on
my hand now is a terrestrial Northern
Cory frog he's fully metamorphosed from
a a t hole into a frog and being
terrestrial means he's now on land he's
only been an actual fully formed frog
for maybe 2 or 3 days so not very long
at all he's actually gone from a a
little swimming tadpole which has gills
for breathing so he's lost these gills
and developed internal lungs to be able
to breathe he's developed legs he's
popped his little front legs out through
his through spiracles uh and his legs
are fully developed now uh he's gone
from having a a suctorial disc type
mouth part to having an actual
carnivorous mouth part to be able to eat
and not only that his internal digestion
he's gone from having a long spiraling
vegetarian gut um to a short carniverous
cut that a frog would have so his whole
body has effectively changed over the
last over the last two weeks it's a
massive changes for this little guy and
for a species that's teetering on
extinction in the wild this gives
Michael great pride and hope for the
future it's always great personally to
see these little guys coming through at
this time of year when they're
metamorphosing cuz it means everything
been done right their tal husbandry
their frog husbandry up until now is
great and they're getting through as
little frogs for me that brings a great
sense of personal satisfaction that that
these little ones here are the start of
a new insurance colony and over the next
few years now we'll really build that up
and then I'll be feeling a lot more
secure that should anything happen in
the wild um we've got a backup we've got
an insurance population ready to go very
[Music]
happy
teranga is home to a vast array of
animals some you'd love to
cuddle some you'd love to swim
with some you'd love to play with and
then there's those that you'd probably
prefer to step on yeah what do you
think's in
here we work with a whole range of
species up here at the Institute and in
here is definitely one of my favorites
but in order to get him out I've got to
find him first so I just have to try and
gently remove the soil a bit just so I
can find out where he is hello
gorgeous so this is a giant borrowing
cockroach the giant burrowing cockroach
also known as the rhinoceros cockroach
is an unlikely world record holder they
are the heaviest cockroach in the world
and they come from Australia there's
about 4,600 species of cockroach and
he's the heaviest these guys they can
weigh up to 30 G and when you think
about a cockroach that you might have in
your house American and German
cockroaches those guys weigh like 500
times less you know they're 06 of a gram
they're teeny tiny in terms of their
weight these guys are are much much
heavier while Susie Treasures her adult
cockroach keeper Paul is Keen to show
off some of its young there there you
are so this one here is just a uh it's a
sub adult giant baring cockroach these
cockroaches give birth to live young and
the mum is the one that will look after
the babies for up to a year unlike the
uh the PES be the cockp they find around
your house that can give birth to a
couple of hundred uh young each year uh
these give birth to up to about 30 we've
got about 12 little youngst is here at
the moment and they're about a year
old this one's got a fair bit of GR left
to do it get probably about twice this
size but it's definitely old enough now
that Mom would have left it be on its
own so this is just one of many that
we've got here at the moment we do like
to breede them ourselves and they are
relatively easy to breede and the good
thing is that if we're able to be
self-sufficient in that way we don't
have to take them from the wild and they
make great ambassades for the species
and U you they're really cool for our
lessons and and encounters and things
like
that and despite their species
reputation these guys are not pests they
really are completely opposite to what
everybody thinks of when they think of
cockroaches you know they don't carry
diseases they're not dirty or anything
like that and they really do help the
environment out a sentiment
enthusiastically shared by Susie so this
is definitely not your average cockroach
they aren't something to be scared of
they're not gross or creepy who takes
her fondness for this cockroach one step
further I love working with our
cockroaches I think they're so unique
they're so impressive
he um whereas yeah cockroaches at at
home I just don't like
[Music]
them there's been some concerning
brotherly aggression down at the cppy
bar exhibit lately keepers are worried
that as they get older increased
testosterone levels are causing fights
amongst this once tight-knit group the
aggression has ramped up recently and
the the victim or the the the bottom of
the pile so to speak Carlos has been uh
found with bite marks on
him there's one main aggressor Rodney so
to try to temper his moods vet kimbery
and her team plan to insert a device
which will regulate his hormone levels
Kimberly to Capa Bar
Keepers are you guys ready for us to
head down
down great thanks we're heading down
because the cppy bar are new to Tanga
this is New Territory for kimbery I
haven't done a Kappa bear before this is
first Kappa bear anesthesia I think at
Tanga Zoo so we'll see how we go did a
quick research in capara anesthetic and
I found a paper and it looked like it
was going to be a great paper but it was
all in like Italian or Spanish or
something I I did find I found the
temperature temperature range got um
fine well we'll treat it like a giant
guinea pig let see how we
go as Rodney
Waits the Vets prep the
needle how this way but if kimbley hopes
this is going to be easy
okay put that
in Rodney quickly sets her
straight you're okay f
it's Bug House home delivery day so
we're just pouring the Crickets all into
here where a week's worth of live
insects are delivered to almost every
Precinct in the zoo we breed everything
up we when we get it all to the right
stage then we can ship it
out it's been a busy morning of
deliveries for driver
Martin and the last stop is primates you
got for this one box
today thank you very much today we've
got our protein order a bug order from
the bug house looks like we've got some
maggots and some meal worms we've just
got a little bit today so a bit of a
lunchtime
snack in the wild squirrel monkeys Feast
on a balanced diet including fruits
flowers leaves and a r of
insects protein is really important for
these guys so that comes in the form of
insects maybe eggs that they might find
in the wild things like that our monkeys
here love spending every afternoon in
the afternoon sun catching bugs they
love it hey girls what have I got what
do you think
pinky a maggot snack oh
yum so they're grabbing their handfuls
of maggots and running you can imagine
there's 12 Monkeys so they need a lot of
bugs so we supplement them with extra
protein every afternoon let's add a few
meal worms down there the meal worms are
their favorites but it seems like
maggots are pretty popular today too
they've picked out every little
individual maggot so you can see their
little fingers really small very very
clever they're great at using their
hands they're tiny little maggots and
they're excellent at picking up tiny
things like this maggots for these guys
are like chocolate they love it it's
important for these guys that the food
is live though and the movement of those
insects captures their interest and
that's what attracts them to go and
catch those insects so thanks for the
Bug House these guys have had a lovely
little
[Music]
snack the bug house is one of teranga's
behind the scenes
powerhouses but Christine gives most of
the credit to the unsung heroes of the
food supply chain it's really great I
love doing my job I love doing the job
well I'm always told that I'm a little
bit too fussy with my bugs but I I love
them I spend way too much time fussing
over my maggots but they are my pride
and joy I'm very proud of
[Music]
them keepers have noticed that the five
cppy bar brothers are no longer getting
along the aggression has ramped up
recently and the the victim so to speak
Carlos has been uh found with bite marks
on him so vets are hoping a home monal
implant in the main aggressor Rodney
will lower his testosterone levels and
help curb the
[Music]
fighting Kimberly is struggling to
anesthetize Rodney so she hands the pul
syringe to keeper Johnny to have a
crack and Johnny hits the target first
[Music]
go just mean Rodney has received his
do as this is the first anesthesia on a
capu Bara at Tanga no one really knows
how he'll react so nurse Liz keeps a
close eye on him um he's breathing well
the um induction was very smooth and
gentle um so he's in the light made of
anesthesia but so far everything's going
well once he's fully under it's off to
the wildlife hospital for this feisty
little
rodent
okay we'll just wh that yep the door
closed subtract it from that so we can
get
up this is the reproductive implant in
males we use it to help quell aggression
because it'll decrease the testosterone
levels it's going
fine no just glue it
just need to pull it out slowly and
leave it as I pull in the plunger leave
it there so it doesn't come out with
it we only have
one with the implant successfully
inserted fabulous I've just used tissue
glue to close the little hole that I
made and you can't even see that
there's an incision there so it's very
good kimbery takes full advantage of
this first time procedure look at that
little stubby tongue there's not much of
a tongue there to get a closeup look at
the teeth that Rodney's been sinking
into his younger
brothers those in sizes are very much
why we uh we want to stop the biting
Behavior goes through flesh very very
easily so those are huge they look
really nice they're worn well you get a
good idea of how sharp they are side
yeah yeah yeah big teeth to be biting
yeah the other guy with yeah for
sure all right I'm happy to take him
back
with all signs positive Rodney heads
back to his four
brothers I don't think it's going to
take him long give him a little bit of a
pillow that's good yeah that's
great he's had the reversal drug so it
could take apparently anywhere up to 10
minutes from him to to kind of get get
up and start moving around but I'm sure
we'll start to see signs shortly of him
getting uh getting better while today's
procedure has been successful Keepers
must wait a couple of weeks to see
whether the implant works and the group
returns to the original five fun loving
Brothers it's hard to know if this is
this will be successful we don't always
know if it's going to work in in
different species so we're we're trying
this but we'll see we'll see
hello chaps how we doing it's been a few
weeks since Rodney the cppy barer
received his hormonal implant to control
his aggression towards his brothers
hello in the first few days after the
procedure Keepers were concerned with
what they were seeing initially that
implant actually caused them to spike as
part of its regulation process um so we
actually saw the aggression worsen
slightly for the first week or so uh
after the implant was uh put in um but
then that everything started to work and
started to settle down and kick in and
work as it should do um and we've seen a
drop in the aggression since then it's
not ideal to be a hormone implant in
animals if you can avoid it but in this
situation this is the the the best way
to have dealt with this
issue in the wild at this age they would
start to get on each other's nerves test
each other's boundaries and patience and
that's how they would naturally split up
from each other uh and spread that
brotherly the genetics elsewhere um but
because we just have the five brothers
here we don't plan to breathe them at
tangazo um these implants are a great
way to manage their testosterone levels
uh to manage that behavior as well that
comes with it um and to keep them living
very peacefully together uh for the
future and thankfully the target of
Rodney's aggression is benefiting as
well so just behind me uh on my right is
Carlos and you can see on his left rump
there he copped a bit of a nip from one
of his brothers uh which have thankfully
since healed up um but he's had a a much
much better existence since uh those
implants have kicked in um and we've
seen in the last few weeks that his life
and quality of life has increased a
lot that's a fantastic thing from our
point of view as as animal managers and
animal Keepers it's always good to see
our animals in good condition and having
a nice relaxed
life
the zoo's elderly residents hold a
special place in everyone's
Hearts vets and Keepers strive to give
them the best quality of life with
regular
checkups so far so good he's very good
for a
28-year-old it's been a year since blue
the Aging rhino iguana was examined at
the hospital and although he was in good
health for an old lizard time catches up
with us
[Music]
all mo back and now there's only one
rhino iguana in the exhibit hello basar
come on here we go here we
go Blue unfortunately passed away from a
stroke and it was totally
unexpected come
on okay B day today it was heartbreaking
he's one of my favorite animals and you
feel it you feel it every
day now that Blue's gone it's definitely
been a a shift into bat's
Behavior she is the queen of this
exhibit um she's not afraid to tell tell
anyone off of being in her space don't
you bite me and Tabasco is particularly
territorial at meal times this is what
we call a lizard salad and it has end
dive kale sweet potato carrot squash
zucchini H tomato egg everything a a
lizard could ever dream of and she's
also got a couple of little treats here
this morning so she's got some mbery
leaves uh she's got some beautiful
hibiscus flowers which she absolutely
loves some ftles as well she really
loves those greens these guys are her
bous but they will also eat the
occasional insect as well and even on a
full stomach Tabasco lives up to her
spicy name h h h no that's not nice you
ran out of treat so you start biting
people oh okay you're going to do a
storm off now you are a diva you've had
enough of Television you're going to go
see yourself in the sun
okay while it's hard to know whether or
not she misses blue Tabasco does seem to
be enjoying her own space and having
everyone looking out for her she's the
boss she's is the queen of this exhibit
I'm just her humble
[Music]
servant